[Música]
pues bien aquí lo que cargamos las
mujeres esto que nos acompaña durante
mucho tiempo durante la vida es una
experiencia completa de lo que podemos
andar compartiendo y también andar
cargado por supuesto departamento
administrativo en donde tenemos tarjetas
de débito tarjetas de crédito tarjetas
de puntos tarjetas para ir al cine
tarjetas del café que si juntas cuatro
de dar uno más nunca llegas a las
cuadras porque se te pierde pero no
importa en esto tenemos todo un botiquín
que ya lo quisiera la secretaría de
salud pastillas para que se te baje la
operación para 7 porque te sube la
presión cuando te empeñas cuando estás
ansiosa pero si nos da por lo
alternativo entonces traemos nuestras
flores de bach nuestros chicles
relajantes nuestros cuarzos nuestro
rosario
en fin para todo hay sobre todo el
aceite que siempre para quien tenemos al
lado nos ha por demás ponerse que si
hace calor traigo me ha venido y sobre
todo en muchas épocas de nuestra vida
pero si hace frío también traigo mi
charla
traigo mi teléfono y creanme cargando a
gran porcentaje de mis amigos que tengo
en las redes cuestión de mantenimiento
traigo mi cepillo traigo mis pinturas
traigo una cuchara por si se necesita
que yo me recete saray money miel
melipona traigo mi perfume por si quiero
que alguien se me acerque pero también
traigo mi gas pimienta por si quiero que
alguien se me aleje
traigo mis lentes para ver de cerca
traigo mis lentes para ver de lejos y
también traigo por aquí mis lentes de
sol traigo mi librito que me
recomendaron que nunca alcanzó a leer
pero siempre lo traigo con la esperanza
de tener dos minutos mientras hago una
fila o una cola muy bien que más traigo
mi paraguas por si llueve pero también
por si sale el sol ven que el tiempo
está terrible y finalmente por si me da
hambre por si me da más hambre de mis
llaves y esto esto no sé pero como yo
soy la que traigo bolsa yo lo cargó
también
pero estas no son
pero estas no son las cosas que nada más
cargamos las mujeres vean lo que sí
aquí está en el que me acompaña bielli
es una mujer empoderada diríamos algunos
dos o tres hijos ya la que le ha tocado
abrir brecha para poder participar en el
espacio laboral remunerado muchas veces
como que lo re piensa pero bueno de lynn
aquí estamos
el último siglo y sobre todo en los
últimos años hemos tenido infinidad de
cambios y muchas veces hemos pagado un
alto precio en el ya empezamos que es lo
que de verdad andamos cargando las
mujeres primera jornada la primera
jornada implica quienes la que cocinan
alguien tu casa tu desayuno comida y
cena día festivo navidad posadas
tamalitos para llevar tu cumpleaños y el
de todos los demás en una experta en el
aparte nada más implica andar cocinando
hay que ver ofertas ver cupones pasar a
tres lugares donde dice 50 centavos más
barato una cosa pero vale la pena porque
has aprendido que el direc hay eso de
cuidar el gasto muy bien quién lavan el
en tu casa lavar planchar acomodar y
tener una experiencia matemática íntima
por los números infinitos relacionados
con los números de trastes que tienes
que ya va y nunca se acaban siempre
algo que lavar
pero si nos gustan las matemáticas
también una de más cargamos estas horas
que se calculan son entre dos o tres
horas al día que trabajamos físicamente
más las mujeres en una labor no
remunerada sino que aparte que crees ves
que hay una herencia cultural donde tú
eres el pilar de la familia entonces
desde que te enteras que vas a tener un
niño o una niña compras tu manual de
cómo acompañar los primeros pasos luego
qué hacer para no volverme loca con el
adolescente luego cuando mis hijos se
van pares y no se van entonces como
animarlos como animales para que se
vayan
y finalmente pasas a la excepción de
pediatría pero ahí vamos ahí vamos pero
no nada más eso hay que pagar las
cuentas estar al pendiente del foco y
como noticia para todos y por todas el
papel del baño no llega solo al baño que
las mujeres somos las que por lo general
lo conseguimos sin ofertas lo compramos
lo guardamos sabemos dónde está y lo
llevamos tengo por si tenían alguna duda
de dónde es donde aparecerá
en él y la que lo pone
les platicaba que en el y se enrola en
esto de la segunda jornada
entonces compra su portafolio para que
le quepa su lab porque por lo general se
la tiene que llevar también a su casa a
terminar el trabajo que no puedo acabar
en la oficina miren en américa latina
las mujeres ganamos entre 15 y 25 por
ciento menos que los varones si tenemos
un techo de cristal que todavía por más
que saltamos está bastante grueso en
capacitación nos indican muy poco y
cuando al fin se la dedican dices mai no
puedo porque con quién voy a dejar mis
hijos el fin de semana ya que llegó pero
pues ahí la llevamos y poco a poco
estamos abriendo nuevos espacios quiero
hacer una mención especial a todas las
mujeres que no nomás tienen esta primera
y segunda jornada sino que tienen que ir
al monte por su leña tienen que caminar
kilómetros
para ir por su agua y si tienen a
alguien especial a quien cuidar la carga
se triplica se 4 clica allá vamos en la
segunda jornada y en esta segunda
jornada también no crean que nada más es
la máquina es también la emoción de
decir sí que lo estoy haciendo bien
porque me dijeron muchas veces a ver si
yo podía con este trabajo y con este
tema entonces verdaderamente te
esfuerzas y devino nada más te esfuerzas
en poder hacer ese trabajo sino en
cumplir y tienes que dedicarle también
unos momentos a pensar que ese vestido
ya te lo consiste cinco veces en las
últimas cuatro juntas entonces
y finalmente una de las emociones
también es esta problemática del acoso y
de
el acoso y el abuso sexual donde un día
llegas a tu casa y dices yo creo que ya
me voy a hacer de ese trabajo estabas
tan contenta pues sí pero ya no y ahí
vamos ahí vamos y por supuesto poder
superar
ver a tu hijo dentro de 20 años en una
terapia diciéndole a su doctora es que
mi mamá nunca fue a ningún festival
prefería mi trabajo si nunca me dijo
nada ella es mía cia por supuesto que le
hacía todos los deberes
nunca me acompañó a mi primer discurso
de oratoria ahora es político bueno en
fin así que lo puede seguir viendo
tercera jornada tercera jornada porque
culturalmente vemos como heredada una
serie de funciones fíjense por aquello
en que te toca cuidar de los hijos pues
te toca aprenderte también los últimos
57 presidentes de la república mexicana
porque tienes que aprenderte en la
elección para luego con marcela y luego
correr porque olvidó su tarea y lo van a
reprobar y tú tendrás que pagar otoño de
colegiatura de ninguna manera vas
en esto de la cuestión educativa asistes
a cuanta reunión de padres de familia
digo de madres de familia hay en la
escuela coopera con el comité vendes
empanaditas siembras árboles el día de
la reforestación
y por si fuera poco organizas una que
otra posada está en fin
la salud
la salud es todo un caso la salud y esto
les voy a contar un ejemplo cuando tu
hijo tu hija están enfermos quién pones
ungüento para que se mejore la mamá
tu pareja
la amaba
si tu mamá pues la mujer si tu suegra
pues que más no la suegra uno y que
puede ser cuando tú te enfermas pues
agarra la latita que lo pones también
listo te duermes ya estuvo perfecta
la parte espiritual que es fundamental
en el desarrollo biológico de la familia
entonces los llevas al catecismo le
haces el disfraz de ángel de juan diego
a
límites a rezar y aparte arrastras a
toda la familia a los sacramentos porque
bueno el ejemplo muy bien
a la comunidad
puedes ver tales si se mueve
mira en la comunidad
de todo lo que hay si hay una extensión
donde quien va a recolectar firmas para
que pavimente en la calle las mujeres y
luego tienes que recolectaron gas para
que pongan un tope porque ya está
recomendado por el toro para que te me
den el agua potable para las mujeres
luego otros salen en la foto pero por lo
general son las mujeres si en esa
extensión las que piden políticas
públicas las que están al pendiente que
hay un foco porque hay mucho maleante en
fin y mira así estamos en él y creo que
ya acabó no falta falta porque él y su
pareja están en edad de merecer entonces
resulta que llega diez de la noche once
de la noche acuérdense que en el y se
paró a las cinco de la mañana a más o
menos organizar este tipo de funciones
llega la noche
y dice no lo voy a querer si txiki
se dirige a su cama que le dice en el
nivel de mis brazos y en la cama
y una vez que en él se mete calcetines
free entonces dice ahora sí gracias dios
por este día cierra sus ojos no han
pasado ni dos minutos y medio y de
repente
chula
de hecho las se quieren morir
dale chula es fin de semana
y entonces le dice no no hubiese la
tormenta voy a ser mis ojos fuerte para
que vea que existo hoy dormirá pero
bueno te escuchan porque así no se
duerme uno entonces ya que estás
concentrada diciendo lo acabamos de ir a
un taller de empoderamiento femenino que
tengo que decidir por mí sola
y entonces
pero pasan como 30 segundos y frente a
ese taller tan bueno de empoderamiento
femenino surge de repente la imagen de
tu abuela que te dice bastante has hecho
con meterte a trabajar no vayas a
descuidar a tu marido en él
porque lo que un hombre no encuentra en
su casa
lo busca afuera
y frente al empoderamiento y la amenaza
cultural pues le dicen y modos de alejar
por una vez
es cierto
bueno
hoy por hoy las mujeres afortunadamente
hemos sido capaces de caminar por otros
espacios hoy por hoy podemos ir tomando
la decisión de que cargar
que no cargar que emociones llevarnos y
cuales nos sirven para hacer mejor
compañía hoy en especial es un día en el
que honramos a nuestras mamás a nuestras
abuelas a nuestras tías a nuestras
hermanas que se aventaron el riesgo de
ocupar espacios diferentes que tuvieron
que abrir abrir campo y camino y que
fueron criticadas que fueron
discriminadas que les llamaron pecadores
irreverentes feministas sí y que hoy
gracias a tantas como ellas podemos
tener la oportunidad de vivir con mayor
igualdad con mayor equidad y por
supuesto con mayor justicia hoy si bien
tenemos una bolsa ya podemos dejarla
y decidir uno si la quiero cargar si es
importante que la cargue o si otra
persona viene en su búsqueda porque
también le vale la pena acordamos que
las bolsas por lo general traen dos
maneras de agarrarse
hoy recordamos con mucho respeto a cada
una de ustedes a cada una de nosotros
diciendo que estamos convencidas de que
el feminismo es un movimiento que nos
conviene a todas pero también es un
movimiento que nos conviene a todos
porque nos hace ser mejores personas nos
da la posibilidad de vivir en relaciones
más justas y más igualitarias gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]